we have a lot of young people come to  the show and I've noticed recently a lot  of people in our audience use Craigslist  so I thought because I'm a nice guy  would help our audience members make a  sailor connection by showing some of  their craigslist ads right here on the  show right now let's check them out  first up Help Wanted bass play are  needed from my new rock band that  telemarketers rock it wants it young men  to join my book club this month and  every month it's fifty Shades of Grey  for five bucks I will come over to your  house and push your kid way too hard at  the sport of your choice actresses  needed  I'm a former Tony award-winning  playwright currently casting for one hot  night in jail down blankie  I'm gonna miss you blankie but I'm 32  years old ass screw it  blankies not for sale I have weed though  help Mike charity trying to reach my  goal of donating 1 million orgasms very  proud I've never done that after an  orgasm  [Laughter]  you